today the theme is to try to go up from
from propositional logic and look at the
interaction
between propositional satisfiability
technique
and higher level reasoning such as first
order reasoning or
in case of philip is going to tell us
about string constraints
so to see there is a whole other thing
about smt which we are not going to deal
here
but we are looking at lifting
propositional techniques to higher level
reasoning
and so we are going to start fred
phillip is going to tell us about the
string constraints
okay thanks a lot how much time do i
have for this presentation
you have 45 minutes 45 minutes okay
that should work but no one will
complain if you do it in in
40 minutes let's see how fast i can be
so i hope you can see the slides now and
also i hope that you can actually
understand me i'm just trying to use the
microphone of the computer and if that
doesn't work well then i can just switch
to the headset
but i like it actually to speak without
that headset and so far so good
okay great and yeah i think this can be
very interactive so in case you have any
questions then please just interrupt it
anytime
or if in case i make any mistakes then
you can correct me of course as well
um right so this is a bit of a summary
about um our work on string constraints
and also about string constraint solving
in s t
in general and i should start by saying
that this is really joint work with many
people
and so at least the people on this side
and then probably a couple of
other people that i forgot and of course
all the actual contributions go back to
the people on this slide
and all the mistakes are due to me and
um
so the plan of the talk um is to start
with a bit of an outline about string
constraints and why string constraint
solving is interesting
and then i would like to discuss um two
algorithms that we have been
working on ourselves and the one that we
implement in our tool norm
and a newer one in our tool ostrich so
both algorithms for checking the status
variability of string constraints
and quantify free string constraints
so let's start from the beginning um why
are we interested in strings
and well of course everybody who has
been writing programs actually
knows strings so strings are really the
data type number one and
might actually be the first data type
that you see when you start programming
you cannot even write a hell of a
program without
strings and so this is a trend that
actually has become
even more um pronounced in the last
years because now we have um
high level dynamic languages for
instance javascript
or also python um where really most of
the data is in some way stored as
strings so in javascript anything can be
seen as a string in principle
so it's completely impossible to do
things like program verification for
javascript
without being able to handle strings and
so string constraint
constraint solving is also getting more
interesting because these modern
languages have rich built-in libraries
for strings and so these libraries are
themselves implemented in a different
language so
like the library for javascript would
actually be implemented in c or c
plus internally and so that means that
we cannot just take the definition of a
string
operation written javascript but we
actually have to support natively what
operations we are using in the language
otherwise there is no way to do things
like symbolic execution
for instance and right so strings are
used freely everywhere in these
languages
so what are the operations that you're
considering um so you've probably seen
all of these um
well in well papers or when writing
programs
so obviously when we have string
variables we can do things like
concatenate the two variables to get a
new string
we can also say that we want to split
the string variable and with some
certain delimiter symbol and then we get
an array of the substrings
we can do things like varying the length
of a string
we can add tests whether a string is
accepted or
is matched by a certain regular
expression and this can also be used to
extract subparts of the string so we can
have things like
capture groups in the regular expression
and then we can do
like more sophisticated things we can do
things like search and replace
where again the search string can be
possibly a regular expression
and actually the replacement string can
contain
can refer back to the character groups
but it can actually be by itself a
function that is defined
um well to do more complex operations
we can have things like conversions from
string to numbers or vice versa
and we also might have things like
encoding or decoding operations so for
instance changing from utf-8 to utf-16
and
these things so it's a relatively um
complex set of operations
which makes string solving very
interesting
and right i should also mention that
regular expressions are not really
um well what programming languages see
is regular expressions does not directly
correspond to the textbook version of
regular expressions
so we have quite tricky features like um
welcome groups
already mentioned but we can also have
back references to capture groups so we
can say that
a regular expression matches on some
string and then later on in the reg x we
refer back to the same string
and this way we can actually write
regular expressions that do not describe
regular languages but even
context-sensitive languages
and so that's a feature that exists for
instance in javascript
which of course immediately causes all
kinds of undecidability issues
for us and makes the whole thing even
more interesting
uh so what are string operations
commonly used for and so this is a list
of
five kind of big areas and that are
taken from this book from 2017 by
tiffand
and others on string constraint solving
or just the use of string
relevance of strings for verification
security and so typical operations would
be things like input sanitization so we
check
whether user input is actually following
and the right format
or is in some way safe and also
validation so we actually
massage the user input to make it
correct
we use strings to do things like like
generating queries for databases
for instance in sql for handling data in
general
and also like more um dangerous things
like actually dynamically generating
code in the form of strings which is
later executed
uh for instance using the eval function
in javascript
or looking at java you could do things
like dynamically loading classes or
dynamically
defining methods that we want to invoke
so all of these operations are
potentially safety critical
but what makes strings in particular
dangerous is that in some of these cases
we are mixing data and code or we are
converting from data to code
so in particular when generating queries
for databases of course we actually
constructing a string that contains the
data that we want to use to
maybe data that we want to put into a
database but at the same time we are
writing a program
and that is of course a very dangerous
situation
so here is one example why this can be
dangerous and so this is a
well this is of course a slightly um a
very much simplified example
but it is inspired by a real security
vulnerability found on web pages
so this is a small piece of javascript
code that you could find embedded on a
web page
there is some input data which is this
cad string
so this is data that is controlled by
the user for instance the name of a cat
that is input by the user
but in principle that is a string that
contains can have arbitrary contents
and then we are calling various
javascript operations on the stream
so we are doing things like html escape
which is going to replace special
characters with the html code
you're running the escape string which
is doing javascript escape
so it's adding backslashes in the right
places
and in the end we are using the string y
and also the x to construct a piece of
html code
so this button and actually this button
also contains javascript code so
actually this executable code we're
constructing based on user input
and now of course well this is a
dangerous combination because we have
this code controlled by the user
the cad name and we're using this code
to construct a program
so in principle there's a danger that
actually the user can influence what
we're going to execute
or in this case actually what is going
to be executed on the user's machine
because this javascript code of course
is going to run in the browser
right so there are already complicated
operations we have the html escape
and the escape string but also the
assignment to any html
implicitly unescapes some of the code
and so there is one further escape and
escape operation happening and well
you've already seen why this code is
vulnerable but i will just um
recapitulate what is happening
um so the problem is that actually this
code um
is not written completely correctly and
the one possible attack would be to
choose catch
uh to be um this string so starts with a
quote
and so on and in the end actually
there's an alert command
so why is this certain attack well the
problem is that
um the generated html string so the
string that we are generating in the
last command
will contain the code that
we chose the cache to be about in the
escape version
so in particular um the
the parenthesis is going to be the html
code
and now when we are um running the html
unescape
um no sorry i made a mistake so what is
actually going to be
and so this html code actually
corresponds to the same code that we had
in the string
and now when we are assigning to the
inner html field
then this is going to be unescaped and
what we get is actually a string that is
just ending the create catalyst command
and afterwards directly executing the
alert so the problem is really that
and so this alert command is is taping
um from the argument of
create catalyst and instead is going to
be a separate command that is going to
be executed
now the alert is not going to do
anything harmful but in principle of
course this could be any kind of
javascript code so at this point we
would actually be able to
um to attack the uh the browser of the
user
so now you might be wondering so why is
actually this code incorrect because
apparently the programmer did a lot of
effort to actually escape
and try to make the safe but the problem
is that
the escape operations are actually
applied in the wrong order so the
correct version would be to first to the
escape string
and only afterwards to the html escape
so somehow the programmer managed to
swap the order of these escapes and this
is creating a vulnerability
right so this was just to demonstrate
that actually um well this code
operating on strings is very interesting
and
obviously since this about has a
security hole you would like to find
methods to discover
um such vulnerabilities
so well one way is to look at the big
toolbox of verification techniques that
could be applied
and there's a technique that has turned
out to be quite useful is symbolic
execution
for analyzing a code of this kind so we
could actually try to just
um translate the single program path to
our logical formula
and as we will see this formula has to
talk about strings and tests to mention
the string operations of course
and then afterwards we can run an s t
solver or any kind of constraint solver
in principle
had to try to find satisfying
assignments would then represent attacks
so how would this formula look like well
we would go through the
um the path statement by statement and
try to map each of the operations to
some logical function or some logical
constraint
that a constraint server could
understand so the html escape operation
for instance this could be seen as a
function that and then a constraint
solver has to understand
similarly the um the javascript escape
would be another
function then we have this um
concatenation of different strings on
the right hand side and so this could be
seen as a concatenation of five
different strings
w1 w2 and w3 are concrete strings
and the string also the right hand side
also contains y and x which were
constructed in the equations above
then we have the html unescape that is
happening implicitly
and in the end we would like to actually
search for some kind of attack so we
need some kind of target some
attack pattern that we're looking for so
this is often again a regular expression
that for instance expresses that well
the string that you're constructing is
in some way
um well it has a suspicious shape it's
maybe not actually
and not only executing the code that was
part of the original string but it's
also containing other commands
and now of course well this is a logic
formula so if
um we had a magic constraint solver that
is clever enough to understand all these
operations
then we could um find the for instance
the attack that i've shown on the
previous slide
right so this is the wish list we would
like to have solvers that support
basically all the operations that i have
shown and a couple of more things
so particularly we would also like to
support full unicode alphabets
not just ascii because unicode is the
standard nowadays
and also different unicode
representations
right so what are the challenges um and
actually so this is another point that
makes um string constraints constraints
but interesting so there are both
practical challenges and also
theoretical challenges
so the practical research question could
be what is actually decidable about
strings
and i will show some of the interesting
questions here um in five minutes or so
well what is the right string logic or
the right fragment that we would need
for applications um but can also be
solved
effectively and of course how how can we
build efficient solves
for these logics and well many groups
are these days working on this on these
different questions
so for instance or in particular one
outcome um after many years of
discussions
was this smt lip format for strings so
this was released only in february last
year
and so just turned one and actually this
goes back to a proposal
in already 2012 so this actually took
many iterations
to get done um this does not really
answer the question
um what the right string logic is
because as the theory is um is defined
here it's immediately undecidable
so in practice of course all sorts will
look at well we'll consider some
fragment
or they will just try to solve whatever
they can solve and be happy
and right there are also many solvers
many groups are working on solvers by
solving string constraints
and so this is certainly an incomplete
list in case i missed your solve or your
favorite solver then i have to apologize
and so really the journey started with
um this solver harmony
and by vijay ganesh was one of the
organizer when isis of the seminars
and since then many solvers have been
developed including the ones in c3
and the ones the string slot and cvc4
and well many solvers that are focusing
on more specific fragments
of strings philip can ask a quick
question
of course please what is the
relationship between these
and and what classical thing on words
equations
or string equations and macroneen i mean
very classical topics
yes that's a very good question i'm
going to this i'm going to get to this
in two slides actually
okay it's very good very good keep going
okay so the next part is about how we
can actually solve string constraints
and of course i need to go back to the
classical works by um on string equation
on word equations
um so how can we actually solve string
constraints
and writes here we already have the
right equations and so let's look at
some examples and so this is a very
simple word equation
and it's one of the equations that we
had in the example
and well the question is um how could we
decide whether this
equation is satisfiable or unsatisfiable
well in this case it's actually obvious
because the equation is already in a
solved form
so we can choose any values for um the
variables on the right hand side and
then to get the left-hand side we just
concatenate these strings so we
immediately have a
um a closed form description of all
solutions of this equation
and so right you can see that in this
logic we only have
a concatenation well we have string
variables and of course we also have
equation
equations but well it turns out that
this is a very complex logic already so
particularly also negated equations can
be encoded into just positive equations
also disjunctions of equations can be
encoded into
just conjunctions of equations and also
conjunctions of equations can all be
turned into a single equation so just
asking whether a single equation
over over words and with variables
ranging over words
satisfiable is already extremely hard
right so this equation was easy that
that is promising
this is already in solved form how about
this equation
so this is a bit more complicated
because now both left hand side and
right hand side
um are compound terms so they contain
concatenation
and but still it's relatively easy to
handle this equation
and so the main insight that we need to
have is that um
there are three different possible
arrangements of the variables on the
left and
right hand side so the first case would
be the that the x is a short string
so the x actually ends within the u on
the right hand side
so here the upper bar is the left hand
side the lower bar is the right hand
side
and so in the first case the x is short
and ends within the u string
in the second case the x is a bit longer
and ends exactly in the middle of these
two concrete characters a b
and in the third case the x is very long
and ends within the v string
and so these are three possible
arrangements and actually all possible
arrangements up to
um well that are interesting for us and
in each of these cases we can just write
on a closed form solution for the
equations
so for instance in the first case we can
say that well actually the x ends within
the u so we can just split the u into
the first half u1 and the second half u2
and then x has to be u1 and the y
has to be u2 and then a b and then the v
and well the situation looks similar for
the two other cases
so we can split the equation that is
that we started from
and in each of the cases we end up with
simpler equations that are in solved
form
so well again this looks promising and
actually this transformation
has a well a well-known name is known as
lee nielsen's transformation
and it just says in general that
whenever you have a string equation
a word equation that contains
concatenation of both sides
then essentially there are two
possibilities and so either the first
um the first variable on the left hand
side is short
that is this case and and there is a
symmetric case for um where the u is
longer than the x
and then well we can identify some
common substring that we can call t
and we can use that to decompose the
equation
so how about this equation x y
equals 5 concatenated with that well we
can play the same trick we can look at
possible arrangements
and that gives us something like an a
tree of possible solutions for the
equation
in the first case we assume that dx is
longer than the y
so that means x is y concatenated with
some string t
and then z has to be t concatenated with
y and we get the second case
and now we can see that in the second
case the y actually
turns up with both left hand sides and
this actually leads us gives us an
equation x t equals
t z um so these are the two right hand
sides
and now unfortunately we can identify we
can observe that well this is actually
the equation that we started from just
with variables renamed
so we ended up in in a cycle essentially
and well this is actually what happens
in general when we apply this
decomposition rule
and so well this is a an important role
that is actually implemented by many
solvers
but by itself and it does not decide
satisfiability of string equations
because it can get into these cycles
and one has to work very hard to get out
of them again
so well what can be done well because we
can just ignore the cycles and hope for
the best and in some way this is what
most smt servers are actually doing
and they typically add various
additional heuristics and criteria for
detecting that
um that equations are unsatisfiable so
it's not just ignoring cycles
um but there's no very clever technique
either to actually identify cycles and
get out of them
one can identify fragments for which
this transformation so the splitting
rule is guaranteed to terminate
and there are various of these fragments
and the details are not that important
but
essentially all these fragments are
designed in such a way that when we
split exhaustively then eventually we
will end up with a closed phone
solution or of course well we can have
develop these actual decision procedures
and this is for instance makanen's
method
which is essentially applying the
splitting rule um
but then it's also adding an effective
termination criterion
or there's a newer method called
recompression and so the problem with
these methods is that
um all the theoreticians claim proudly
that they are completely unimplementable
and as far as i know actually there's no
solver that is really implementing these
decision procedures
although these well these methods have
been known for many decades
in particular the first one has been
known for a long time
[Music]
okay so what we are focusing on is
essentially the second case so we are
trying to
identify fragments where we don't need
the full power of these complex decision
procedures
but we can just essentially apply
splitting and it will terminate
but then we can add various other
operations that are interesting
and i'm not going to give a full
definition well actually i'm going to
define the straight line fragment but
i'm not going to define the other
fragments
and because the definitions are a bit
technical and not that interesting
actually
um but in principle any of these could
work
um right as i said actually many of
these solvers do implement
the splitting rule that i've shown so in
particular that's be the case for c3
sdr and also cbc4 and also many of the
other solvers
but in combination with various other
techniques
okay so this was actually the first kind
of constraints so just the word
equations
and this already turned out to be a bit
of a nightmare to solve in a complete
way
but of course we are not satisfied with
just equations we want more
so in particular we want regular
expression constraints
and we needed those for instance for the
motivating example for this
injection attack and so it turns out
that regular expression constraints
cannot be directly reduced to word
equations
but also the combination is quite well
behaved so the decision procedures
perverted equations can easily be
extended to also handle regular
expressions
so this is fine well but then we would
also like to look at length constraints
we would also
add constraints that the length sound
string x maybe equals the length of
some string y or in general we would
like um well
arbitrary length constraints and
prescribe arithmetic
and well this turns out to be very
interesting and in fact the decidability
of this combination of word equations
and length constraints
is still open and has been opened for a
very long time
and well even more interestingly even
when we look at very simple fragments of
word equations
for instance quadratic word equations
where each variable can occur at most
twice in an equation
um so this is very simple because
they're very simple decision procedures
for this fragment
but the combination of the lengths
length constraints or even then
turns out to be very complicated so even
here the desirability question is still
open
well and then we would like to have
these more complex operations like the
html escape
and these can in a very general sense be
captured as a letter to letter
transduction
and i'm going to show some examples for
that and if the time is permitting right
and well if we had transduction then
immediately we end up in a relatively
simple setting but
but things are completely undecidable so
transaction actually immediately
captures everything else so using
transaction we could also
um represent concatenation all the
equations so in principle
we would only need transduction here
right and so this is kind of the
spectrum of what we could do
so we have um very complicated word
equations
that are decidable but complicated and
we have transaction which is
in principle simple but undecidable and
now we would like to define fragments
that are interesting for solvers and
interesting for applications
in the spectrum and so i mentioned these
two different tools that we had
norn um and ostrich so in norn we had a
relatively simple fragment for word
equations so it's even simpler than
quadratic
but then in addition to that we had full
support for regular expressions
and also full support for length
constraints so this this particular
combination is decidable
and in the second tool i mentioned in
ostrich we actually added a bit of
transduction
but then we could not add length
constraints at the same time so again
this combination of length constraints
and transaction
would immediately give us undecidability
so this is a a green fragment
and well there are many other
interesting fragments that one could
carve out here
right so i think 15 minutes left um
so in the presentation i first talked
about norn and which is supporting these
different parts
but i think it will jump over this part
and instead directly talk about ostrich
which is the much newer work
so this tool norm was published at calf
in 2014
so it's already a bit older although
compared to other tools it's
well it's still handling a relatively
rich logic
of string constraints
right so what norn is supporting are
essentially um all the parts that are
have a green check mark yeah so
concatenation
um within this fragment of word
equations length constraints regular
expressions
and well also arbitrary finite alphabets
can be handled efficiently
but we don't have things like search
replays or
escape operations and so on and this is
really what we wanted to solve
in this second tool ostrich
and well that leads me to this part
where i want to talk about how to solve
string constraints going backwards so
starting from the end
and so this is in some way this is also
one of the key steps underlying norm
but we look at it in a more general
fashion here
um so let's consider a word equation
and actually later in ostrich we're
going to see this as an assignment
of x concatenated with y to some new
variable set
and so what we're using as the main
reasoning step in ostrich is back
propagation so we assume that we have
this equation
and we have some regular expression
constraint about the result about the
set
and to say this in some regular language
l and
so the main step we're doing is well
we're going to back propagate this
and from the l we're going to derive um
constraints about
uh about the input variables x and y
and so now this is not possible in this
form in general um but it's always
possible to find a finite number of
cases
so we can always say that um if the
image of this concatenation is some
regular language l
then we kind of then we can find a
finite set of regular language
pairs l1i and r2i
um so that they're unique corresponds to
sector of the pre-image
and so this is essentially the lemma
that is underlying this so whenever we
have a regular language
l and then there is a finite set of
languages of pairs of languages
this form so that um
x compared to negative with y is an l if
and only if
x is in one of these and pairs l one i
and y is in the other regular language
and right so here i should actually say
that well these languages are there in
regular languages so we can describe
them using automata
yes i suspect that the lemma is stronger
it gives you probably an algorithm to go
maybe from a regular expression for l to
regular expressions for l1 and l2 right
yeah that's right yeah so we are
internally always working with the
trommeter but in principle this is very
simple we just need a disjunction over
the states of the automata
of the automaton you just have to say
that whenever
um whenever you're looking at a run of
the automaton then of course um the
recognition of the x has to stop in some
state of the automaton
and from that point on we're going to
recognize the y
and so this n will be bounded by the
number of states of the automaton
but i'm sure you could also directly do
this on the level of regular expressions
if you want
almost all fun yeah great yeah
right so this is um what can be done for
concatenation
and well there's a simple lemma that
explains why this is possible
but it turns out that actually many
other functions um have the same
property
so whenever we have some function f and
i'm going to call these functions
admissible
then if you know some constraint about
the result you can
propagate and get constraints about the
arguments
and in general we are going to have well
this finite disjunction
and so this these are the functions that
we call admissible
i should um not following exactly the
structure of the slides but
so we call functions admissible whenever
the pre-image
of regular language is l and can be
represented in this form so finite union
of cartesian products of regular
languages and if you know about
transducers then you also know that of
this
shape is called recognizable so
a function is admissible whenever the
pre-images of regular languages are
recognizable relations
right so now i should jump back because
i actually skipped all the interesting
part
interesting parts um right so what is
the fragment of formulas that we are
actually handling
and so these are these straight line
formulas that i mentioned
so we are supporting straight line
formulas or we can also call them
programs
containing regular expressions and
assignments and the assignments can
involve
application of admissible functions to
string variables
and well as we can prove this is a
decidable fragment as well
so what are straightened formulas not
straight-line formulas are simply
conjunctions of constraints
but each of the conjuncts is either a
regular language constraint
or it's an assignment of the result of
applying some admissible function to a
vector
of string variables and valid straight
line
um because all the variables on the
left-hand sides are pairwise distinct
and we may only use variables in um
in constraints that are following later
so it's a bit like the ssa form of a
program we can only
use variables once we have assigned a
value to them and we cannot assign
values twice
and here would be an example of a
formula in straight line
and so this formula consists well
contains both regular expressions
uh so x x is an input variable and um is
assumed to be in this regular expression
a star b star
and we also have applications of
admissible functions like reverse
or replace o so replacing all
occurrences of a with b
and now the question is well is this
conjunction of constraints
um satisfiable or in other words is
there some input x that will satisfy all
the assertions
and so the assertions that are regular
expression constraints
so to answer this we're going to use
this principle of back propagation so
we're going to
and go backwards in the program and and
we are going to
well we will try to figure out
constraints for the x that we need to
satisfy all the constraints
well so first of all and how can we do
this we know that z
is in the language b star and that is is
the result of replacing all a's with b's
well that of course means that y needs
what needs to be written in the language
a or b star because then all the a's
would have been replaced by the replace
all
so that means we can just remove the
last assignment instead say that y has
to be an a
b star and now this can be conjoined to
the regular expression about the y
which in fact turns out to be stronger
than the second one so you can just
actually remove the last regular
expression
and then the y is the result of applying
the reverse operation
so reverse will just um change the order
of the characters well if the y is in b
star a star
then of course the reverse of y i'm
sorry and so if the y is in b star a
star
um then of course the x must have been
in a star b star because reversing it
gave us
the y word so we can also eliminate the
last
assignment and replace it with a regular
expression axis and a star b star
and that also turned out to be the
constraint that we had in the beginning
so
it's a precondition and now this last
regular expression constraint is
satisfiable and from that can conclude
and that actually the whole program the
whole formula is satisfiable
this is easy to solve
and right so this is the overall idea in
ostrich we are solving constraints
using back propagation and here are some
functions that we can support in the
setting
so we've already seen that there's a
slimmer about regular expressions so we
can
about sorry about concatenation and so
we can immediately
um identify concatenation to be
admissible
um you can also handle things like
replace and replace all
and in fact replace all even when the
replacement string is a variable
and so this is already quite powerful so
this is more than
um i think any other s p server and
apart from
um our solver ostrich can actually
support and decide
and we can very easily enter the reverse
operation
and we can handle any functions that are
defined by transducers
and this can even um those can even be
two-way transducers even that can be
handled here
and we can also encode things like
conversions between different formats
um or things like escape operations
quite easily here
and right of course i need to show an
example of a non-admissible function as
well
so for instance a function that is
converting a number from urinary to
binary representation
and so this is not admissible because
the pre-image of a regular language
under this function is in general not
regular as can be seen quite easily
so here we can encode exponentials
directly of course
and right so this diagram essentially
shows the ostrich procedure
i can maybe quickly go through this but
i think i've explained the main idea
already
and so in ostrich we will start from a
conjunction of
function applications and this is one
half of the straight line program
and we will also have some regular
expressions and so these are initially
called the active regular expressions
because we still have to solve them
and then in each step we're going to
pick one of the function applications
and one of the regular expressions and
about the result of the function
application
then we're going to compute the
pre-image of the regular language under
the
function f and so this will be a
disjunction in general
and so we're going to pick one of the
disjuncts and focus on that
and move that back to the to the active
regular expressions
so essentially at this point we have to
make a decision and then do
and not follow a particular branch of
the search space
and so the y becomes passive at this
point
because we know that there is only a
single function application producing
the y
and so we don't actually have to
propagate again for the same y
yeah but later on we might have to check
whether this y constraint
um is consistent with other active
fractal expression constraints about the
y
that we might get so right so we pick
one regular expression we pick one
equation
we compute the pre-image and then we
curse we recurse over the new regular
expressions
and each time we are adding a new
regular expression of course we have to
check whether it is consistent with
expression that we already have and if
it is
then we just recurse and pick the next
equation in the next regular expression
if there is a conflict then we have to
backtrack and in the style of smt then
we're going to compute a conflict set
and we're going to back jump as far as
possible
and follow different branch of the
search space
and right so some of the steps um in
more detail so we have to check
regular expression consistency well that
essentially boils down to
checking where the end the intersection
of regular language is sorry
yes yes the intersection of regular
languages is empty internally
and this could be done by computing
products of course and so this is in
well in theory this is expensive but in
practice this is actually something that
can be done quite efficiently
then we have to compute conflict sets
and those we are minimizing in a greedy
way
essentially smt style and also we have
to compute pre-images
and those are essentially automata
constructions we are applying
and so how do these look like for the
admissible functions that i mentioned
well for concatenation we have to do the
splitting over automaton states
and replace and replace all and can each
internally be reduced to later
transducers
and well that construction can be
optimized in various ways
uh reverse is very easy because um
computing the pre-image of reverse just
means that we have to
revert all the automaton transitions
and linear functions defined by
transducers can be handled using a
product construction and projection so
we're projecting out the result to get
the constraint over the input
essentially and right so this is
essentially everything we need
to solve the example that i started from
so this constraint
and can be solved um within a couple of
seconds by our tool ostrich
and of course after we have encoded and
things like the escape operation in a
good way
and how do we encode this cake
um so it turns out that these can be um
defined as letter to letter transducers
um so these are about machines that
read some input string and produce
outputs so the automaton automata
working on multiple tracks and uh so the
transducer um
for encoding something like the html
escape would essentially look like this
and this is only a small part of the
transducer though because in the actual
escape we look at many more
special characters but essentially well
we start from the initial state
and each time we are reading one of
these special characters um
we're just replacing the character um
with the html code
and then go back to the to the to the
heart to the main state
[Music]
and well that is all we need to actually
solve this example
[Music]
uh right so time is running out and
there are various extensions that could
be presented here
so i started from the straight line
fragment
but of course it would be interesting to
handle more general fragments of word
equations
and for instance one can observe that um
vanco can go to a slightly more
expressive fragment like the acyclic
fragment
where we can have compound terms on both
sides of the equations
we cannot easily go to full word
equations as well
and another very interesting direction
is how we can add things like
computing the length of strings and all
porting operations
like um string add which gives us one
particular character in a string for
computing the substring
and so this combination of integer
operations and spring operations this is
very interesting
and so we had a paper about this at art
for last year
and that is essentially generalizing the
whole framework to also deal with
integer functions
uh right so then i'm actually staying
within the time so
um i did not talk much about norm um but
um well
i i gave a description of the problem it
is solving
and uh so well these are two decision
procedures for particular fragments of
them
of uh string constraints uh covering
things like regular expressions
length particular fragments of word
equations
and also other functions that that are
admissible
and so in general string solving is a
very exciting area it's very active
there are many groups that are
that are working on tools that are
publishing each year at cuff they're
going to be
at least half a dozen of submissions
about um string constraints
and right i also started from these
research questions and so all three of
them are extremely interesting
and there's still a lot to do
so thanks a lot for your attention
i'm happy to take more questions thank
you philip thank you very much
um let me use my privilege and ask some
of the
first questions and a question about the
fragments
and i want to ask about two aspects of
them one
like in first of the logic which are
insideable and we study fragments
we also look at what is the complexity
of each decidable fragment
yes is there a similar study here of the
of the
conjunction complexity and there's some
result characterizing the complexity of
each fragment
yes of course but it's something you
would have to do actually for each
fragment in particular
so i was thinking that you might
be asking about this so i prepare a
slide ah
very good unpredictable but now where is
it i cannot find it
right so these are some results and for
different fragments and that you could
handle within ostrich
and so here the complexity really mainly
depends on what kind of operations you
consider and so of course if you only
have regular expressions
the problem is going to be b space and
so depending on what kind of
functions and what kind of transducers
you're adding um well you're going to
get more or less terrible performance or
terrible complexity
and of course well at some point you
also end up with undecidable things
like this combination replace all of us
immediately would give you undecidable
fragments my other questions about the
fragment and again it's motivated by
my familiarity with the decidable factor
in first of the logic
is the questions are these fragments
useful
so in first order logic turn out that
one decidable fragment is useful the
beneficial fragment is useful
the other fragments of theoretical
interest only and they have
i have seen no application you know the
ackermann class that they
get the class i just don't know of any
application of it
now you started by motivation for
application mostly i would say from
security applications that we need to do
analysis
do the desirable fragment match the
needs that come from the application
side
yeah and to suddenly agree but not
completely i think you're right that's a
very good question
well it's one of the research questions
really so
um so i think this constraint um is not
unrealistic so this is actually coming
from a real
program well it's a very much simplified
program but still
and so this is ending up in the fragment
that i've described so i think that is
one argument actually that the fragment
is not completely useless
um but um it's very easy to also go
beyond the fragments so for instance
when you do symbolic execution
when you're executing an if and else
statement of course you will immediately
get a positive and a negated version of
the condition
the conditional and so that would
immediately also give you negated
equations
for instance and so that would already
push you beyond the fragment
so i think the fragment is not useless
and but it's also brittle i think you
can easily
cross the boundary but
i would say that all these fragments are
actually motivated by applications
so they're not just completely
theoretical
other questions from the audience
phillip uh one quick question
since you're already on this slide uh
you explain
how do you call html escape
but how do you model attacks
how do you model what exactly sorry at
the the attack
uh you see all right yeah yes
right yeah that's actually also a good
question and i think the typical answer
would be that you assume that you have
some kind of catalogue of common attacks
so kind of you need to have some domain
knowledge you need to understand html
and you need to understand actually
what string would be dangerous when you
can construct it and then this is
something that you could
that you could define as a regular
expression um but it's a good question
so at this point actually we need to use
input it's a bit of a specification
actually
you would say that um you're not
supposed to be able to construct a
string of this particular shape so say
if you are constructing sql responses
you could say that actually
um whatever you want to get as a final
query must only
well it must not do things like delete
for instance which is something that you
could characterize as a regular
expression
thank you thanks
tomas do you have any questions
i see a question on the chat from thomas
okay can you
hello i should yes
go ahead thomas now i'm online um
can you um quickly you went over another
slide
where i uh quickly saw the class and p
or something could you show the game
please the slide
how complex
went over it very quickly which one was
that
actually i don't remember it
yes right so this is actually a whole
different presentation uh so this was
about um
so when we have this fragment that we
handle in ostrich and what kind of
length constraints could be
and could we add to this fragment and
right um so actually so one option that
we
that we considered was that and we were
investigating actually which length
constraints actually make a difference
in the sense that
they really um require an extension of
the fragment
and so it turns out that actually many
of the constraints that he would add
although they talk about length in
principle they could just be reduced to
things like regular expressions
so for instance um if you had a length
constraint like the length of x
equals to three well that could just be
turned into direct expressions with the
access to b and sigma
times three and so on and of course then
there are other constraints that you
could not translate
through rectal expressions in the same
sense for instance length of x
equals the length of y and so this can
be formalized as this notion of um
a formula being one addict so formula is
magnetic
if it is equivalent to a formula over
just
one eddie predicates and homonym
predicate only talks about a single
variable
and obviously each magnetic predicate
can then be directly turned into regular
expression
and so the point about the np
completeness is
how difficult is it actually to decide
whether a formula impressive arithmetic
is magnetic or can be turned into this
magnetic form
and so in our in each car paper last
year we figured out this is co np
complete
okay yeah so it's this is uh yeah
this is also super interesting but it
will be a different presentation thanks
okay thank you